This video is going to be very interesting about how you can participate and complete your journey.
In this video, I am going to share with you
three tips which will help
you a lot in your chances of acceptance and in your journey.
Don't skip this
video and it is going to be very interesting, the
video is going to be very interesting, my name is Surya, you are watching
Kothi Tax, let's start
[Music]
So here is an
international program in which Google
provides you a step and if you want
any  Let's build open free software, let's
talk in our time. Google
started it in 2005 and it helps every year during summer
time, i.e. in the
middle of August. Let's talk now and
within the program, it is  There are
many organizations in the program which have
open software programs running in their market, that is, if
you talk about
video link or you must have heard
about PLC media player, then this is
a very big software in which
you can  For years, people have been
playing their movies or videos on it
and I also do the same, so they also take
part from such organizations, there are many
products available in the market
with free software, you can download them in the market,
you can get Linux.  You have to
pay for Windows but you
don't have to pay for Linux. You download it for free
and can do it easily. There are
organizations that have free
software and they have
given you projects here.
And here you work on those projects, you work on the
project history,
here you have to select a project
and you code on it. During the
summer time, you are adding a feature in it
or you are adding it completely.  In a way, when you are
building a new project, it totally depends on you,
what kind of idea you have about the project.
He has given you a project idea,
so to understand it more, let's
go through its timeline and
understand it in depth, how the time  When you have to
organize it and then you have to write your proposal
letter, then to
understand it completely, you will have to see the timeline,
so to see its timing, go to the Min website
and let us see how it
works and where you should start from.
Here I am, I have searched for the website of G-Shop
and I have already visited G-100
website, so here I am writing about the
2023 program, so here we
will move down towards its timeline to
understand it better.  For this, what should you do in which page,
then I have reached the cooler below
here, if you click on the 2023 program,
then a timeline will come below here,
which according to your time zone, there are
different time zones according to different countries.
So if we look at the time zone
according to India then it
is situated so here we can see
that the program announcement date which I had
told in the beginning of the video is 12th
December 2018
or those which are available in the market, we will
give you all those applications after starting them.  They
will give and that means they will keep their
own projects, these are my projects on which they
can work by contributing, so
here their deadline which is will end on 7th February,
after that there will be a notification date by which
they will come to know that we have been selected.
After that, the
organization will announce which ones are to be accepted and
which ones are not accepted. As soon as you get to
know, after that you will
also get to see the interval between 22nd to
20th March in which you can select
your organization.  Type of work you
want to do and whose project you want to
select. After that you have to
select the proposal which means there
is an application period in which you can
participate if you know.  So contribute there,
because if you want to contribute then
how will you contribute in any project,
you have to
keep an idea on any project, I am interested,
today I picked up an organization of machine learning
and
went to their project and I found the project
very good.  I felt that I should reduce it a bit
and I can keep this idea in it
and it will be enhanced by this. This is the
whole
idea of ​​this story. This whole proposal can be kept in the
same way as you would make a report in college.
What have I understood and what should
I do in this and how should I complete my audio in the project, how will I
complete the project, then
you have to tell all this inside this application, then there are mentors within the organization.  The special thing that will provide
is your application.
After the review, you feel worried whether
your project or idea is
selected or not. After that,
as soon as you get accepted, then
during this period.  That is,
after the accepted projects are announced, you
go to a face like say
in the support face, here you will
join the community, the mental person will be with you, the person
of the organization with whom you will be reducing,
you can ask him dot.  You
can take help from him who will help you in building,
so this is the time here,
you have 12 weeks, so in this period you will
do the complete code, you will
be improving your idea, so here we will talk about
which  C organizations come
and how do you have to organize, for that
I have a tape for you, it will
save a lot of your time. My main point is
that you should
go to the same organization from which you
get your domain, support it on your web.  If you have done walking
or you have some early experience,
you can also go into it like
I did without any experience, so I will
look at the
projects in the same organizations and select one project from them
and implement the idea on that as to
what I can do in it.  If
I can, then
where should we start from here? If the program
announcement date is happening here and we do
n't have to wait till February, then we can start from now itself.
Many organizations have already
done this right from the beginning.  Organization is selected,
friend, I have to understand its base code like
source code, but the
number one is that first of all you should
select your organization and
understand its base code and source code so
that for you  How will it be easy or
difficult for you, so
you can review this thing a bit,
how will you find it from the beginning, so
here we have, like I have
searched for starting, below
you will
get the link of an organization.  If you go there, like
I went to this link, 2000
program organizations will be shown to
you, there are many types of programs
here, now all the pay are available here, you will see
all the organizations shown here,
development based on data.
Which comes
to me, I like I, so I have
artificial intelligence, I have XP, so
I will search on I, any one of
my editions
here, as if I searched, there are
many organizations, so here
I have open when.  Tenses of Ready Good
Framework Work of Machine Learning So you will be
attracted to such organizations in which your
domain should be related to the organization, please
support me, I have done 10 things here
and also
what will be the benefit in this that if you have more resume,
one point will be added.  That I have done this
in projects and I have implemented this idea
in this. As soon as you open the page, you get tension,
what you will get is that here there
is an email option on the side and here there is a pay view ideal
step, so this is the complete page
and some below.  Projects: You
can see the previous projects of people, how did they
implement their idea, did they
do it and by doing it, they got
selected by implementing their idea,
so here they must have
also given you the mantle of being with us.
The in this here pe to
jab aap idea koi khi nahi organization
hai aur saal ad hoti hai [
Music]
You can try to understand their project history and source code or base food.
Now when I go to the pe view idea list here
So here look at me, different
organizations have different pages,
like here I have opened a Google document,
I have online but which
websites are there from where you will have to read all this,
so here you will get everything about
how.  How to apply and how you have to
write an application, they also have some format.
We depend on the organization that they
want it in this format.
I asked, are you an attitude team, are you going to add
functionality, how are you going to
start the thing?  You propose,
complete here, you apply. If you are considering
you are good first out
DFU, then you have to go through the steps once
because frequently ask question means that
I, many of you have single
quotients in your mind.  If you can, then
they will help you, from here you
can read this thing, then let's talk
about project history, there are different
projects, by idea, it means that one company has
so many projects, how many
organizations do they have, different types,
meaning yours.  There will be variety in the projects
but you will have to research very well and you will have to
look at each organization once for yourself to find out
which project you
want, then implement your history accordingly and
why will you have to find the best van
and  Let me tell you that you
can give three proposals, please suggest that
I send one proposal to one organization and the second
proposal to another organization and the
third proposal has a limit on the proportion.
You can send three promotions to all three organizations,
so please suggest me less.
I want to do Kaggle like development
gx examples and demos for an
application so here I have a lot of
things for us and seeking for g show student
got interested in continue like here
such students are talking about continue
like you so
they  It is fully written that how will you
reduce it, so
you will be seeing here by rapping from here, when I
click, it will take me to kitup,
here will be their code, this
is the base code, how will you run it here
from long ago.  If you have contributions then you can read here
how
you will start doing it, how you have to run this thing, you must have
understood the whole thing
here, after that how you will present your idea,
from here you will get the complete
project.  You will have to start making the board,
first you have configured the date thing,
so tip number, it is your turn which
I told you in the beginning that
you can understand the base from the beginning itself,
pick up the organization which
comes from a long time ago.  Also sir,
tension flow is being selected for that since last three years,
so I will keep tension flow once
considering that if I get it this year, then
I have projects for it and its base
code is like this, then I will do all this first.
Meaning, even before starting the application,
many of these points are
already understood and it becomes
easy for them, so you can also do it in such a way
that first of all you understand the base code
and after that you start implementing it.  That
means you can try
implementing some of your ideas in the same old project,
so that you can
practice it and you know, when the
time comes to write a proposal, it will
become very easy for you.
Now let's talk a little about organizations.
From the proposal side, how to write a proposal
and how to do it, you should
connect with those people who are already
part of the project and their mentors, that is, have you
seen in any organization recently and every specific of the project.
Project Mental is like
if I go through the Sam of Code, here I will
tell you that in this D Mental will be
Kevin Morphy D. In this you can see
you can
move the cabin in the free cylinder here
which will be our mental in this project.
For this, there is a specific metro for every project,
you can connect with them,
so when you go, you will get to know here,
I will click here, so
who is this, where can you mail them
and you can send your idea first.  You can propose to them
and you can connect with them and you can ask about them, you can ask
your doubts
related to the project and how can I run
these things because these
organizations are already selected and the
people are in three-  Since four years, You Know
's application has been selected again and again,
so I believe that by
making such smart moves, you can connect with people
and increase your chances. The
second thing you have to keep in mind is that when you go to
G-Shop.  If you have taken admission in I, then you are
going to the community, but in that
community, you will also meet new content there, so
there you have to
maintain a good behavior and this is the only time when the
deadline of proposal comes, your chance.  The importance of
being accepted ends, you do
n't stop contributing, sometimes
stalls near mentors are vacant, propose,
sorry if you have proposed, then there are
proposal
reviews, they review and select so many people
that only a few people are in their sight.  Even then they keep
talking about giving me extra stalls and if I keep
two
extra stalls and if I select one more and
continuity, then that is a
good behavior of yours, that is, you are
helping the other contribution
in the community.  Can select you
and how do you know how other
contributions are helping you in coding?
What is your behavior and how do you like this? This is not all about
coding means you have to complete the
entire project. This is all about
comment. Asian how do you continue?
How are you pushing, what
things are you keeping in mind,
these are some things that are going on in the rules and regulations guide,
you can easily select [music] that you follow the timeline and
follow the guidelines of the community and common
Maintain a good image of yourself and
connect with people and
contributors, so gas in this
video, have learner award, some
interesting facts and about G, so
that's all in this video, I will meet you
soon in the next video which is
very  It is going to be interesting and will be
very helpful for you for the software which is
on get up and get up so let us
talk there because mostly the company
keeps its source code on get up only and
you are cloning it from the main source only.  You are downloading
like if you are suitable then from there you are
downloading how you
can do that thing more frequently and in that way you can perform, for that you should know Gate and
Gate very well so you
know Python.  If
you know the language, you can watch my video for that,
which is coming very soon, Get and Get,
here in this video we get only this much gas, till
then in the next video
[Music]